to verse every existence multiplied by
possibility and spread out an infinite
measure now there is a malevolent force
at work one driven by a singular goal
the destruction of old there is there's
a wave of antimatter sweeping across
this universe destroying everything in
its path I brought you all to earth
thirty-eight because this is where the
monitor wants you to make your stand
right so we are going to need a bigger
team you want some help the entire
universe needs you crawl space and time
exists seven heroes who can save the
multiverse I'll find him
you are Clark Kent right briefs Kate
we need your help to stop this
antimatter way all right
then flash has the played a bit
evacuated yeah not entirely it's not
time one thing is certain everything we
know
everything there is and everything
they're ever boss is doomed
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
a brand new crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer it's supposed to be the final
really big trailer but they'll probably
a couple more promos there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs we had a whole
bunch more footage of Tom Welling
Smallville Superman implying that he's
gonna be one of the Paragons all the
crossover episodes will start airing
next Sunday so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything of course I'll do Easter Egg
videos for all the episodes careful for
spoilers for things that have happened
on the other show so far because I'll be
talking about that stuff but the big
deal here is the monitor finally
explaining the multiverse in crisis on
Infinite Earths to all the people
previously he just been assembling
heroes and pushing them around like
chess pieces on a board he never
mentions the anti-monitor by name he
just refers to him as this malevolent
force behind the antimatter wave is
going to destroy everything like Tom
Cavanagh is pariah wells at the end of
the trailer says one thing's for certain
we're all doomed
they literally destroy supergirls earth
because a lot of this is all taking
place on her earth so that might be one
of the big cliffhanger moments as the
trailer footage plays out it looks like
the next big world on the chopping block
is this version of Argo city where
Cara's mother played by Erica Durance
was that was also where this version of
Superman and his Lois Lane went for the
birth of Superboy Jon Kent that we saw
in the last trailer good thing they came
back to earth 38 just in time but
because of the way they cut this trailer
it's kind of hard to figure out where
all these scenes are happening in the
first three episodes because of some of
the characters that show up I know some
of this footage is from the third
episode it's not all from the first
episode but the reason why why the
Harbinger is probably telling them that
the monitor wants them to make their
stand on earth 38 supergirls earth is
because Supergirl is the first episode
of the crossover this Sunday as you see
during the trailer though things do not
go too well for them they're completely
doomed so it sounds like whatever it is
they're trying to do it's not successful
Oliver talking about getting a few more
people for their team is probably
something from the first episode though
because then you see Barry's show up in
a completely different scene do you guys
need some help there's a bunch of
footage of Earth 90 Barry Allen John
Wesley Shipp in the other trailer he
only shows up at the end of this trailer
too so there's a lot of people that
aren't in this trailer that will show up
during the first couple of episodes this
footage of Oliver asking earth 38
Superman for his help seems kind of
weird where they put it in the trailer
because most versions
Superman would be the first persons to
lead the charge normally it would be
Superman going around collecting all
these heroes there on the Waverider so
maybe this is them taking the way
brighter to Argo City before it gets
destroyed to pick him up like hey this
is big crisis coming that you don't know
about because you've been on vacation
with your wife who just gave birth to
your new son
the monitor explains the seven Paragons
there was a scene during the flesh that
kind of teased that - with pariah Welles
that I'll talk about in a second but as
far as I know the Paragons are supposed
to be Oliver the flash or 38 Superman
Tom Wellings Smallville Superman as this
footage implies Kingdom Come Superman
who doesn't really show up that much
during this trailer Martian Manhunter
and Kevin Conroy is Batman but there's a
difference between being one of the main
characters of the air / shows and being
a Paragon so not all the mains are
supposed to be Paragons if there's only
gonna be seven Paragons in the way they
cut this trailer implies that a bunch of
non main characters will also be
Paragons like it's implied that earth 38
Lex Luthor is also one of the Paragons
big twist that one of the big villains
is also supposed to be one of the big
heroes of crisis because he's such a
genius and he can help them out
love the footage of Superman and iris
going to get Smallville Superman who
just seems completely chagrin to see
them like what what is going on here if
you never read smallville season 11 the
comic book tells the story of what
happens to him after the Smallville
series finale when he fully becomes
Superman and he puts the suit on there's
a version of Justice League on this
earth there's a version of Batman a
Wonder Woman most of the other big
Superman specific comic book characters
and Justice League characters he has all
these adventures with them we're not
quite 10 years out from the Smallville
series finale but Marc Guggenheim the
showrunner on arrow and one of the
executive producers and managers sort of
this big crossover endeavor said that
they would be treating the smallville
Season eleven comic like canon for the
purposes of the crossover so when they
show up on this earth that's why
Smallville Superman looks like he's none
the worse for wear got a whole lot of
city miles on that version of Superman
one of the other most interesting things
that they do in this trailer is
canonised Kevin Conroy is Kingdom Come
looking Batman as the Batman of Earth
one at least as what they're implying
based on this interaction because he
instantly recognizes bat woman as if
it's his version of Kate Cain his niece
that he's known this whole time I'm
totally cool with them doing this
meaning that Kevin Conroy has been the
man of Earth 1 this entire time we just
haven't known it till now the
alternative would have been to have him
come from another earth my biggest
question for him now is how are they
going to treat all the Batman the
Animated Series and Batman Beyond Easter
eggs since that's where most people know
Kevin Conroy from and typically what
they've done with big actors like this
from other DC properties is they try to
include Easter eggs from the places that
they came from but because this is a
live-action now it's getting really meta
you just have to pretend like what if
Batman the animated series had been a
live-action show that would be one of
the best DC shows of all time because
Batman the Animated Series is not just
one of the best animated series of all
time it is one of the best TV shows of
all time just by itself we finally see
all those shadow demons that they teased
in Nora's future newspaper during the
flash season 5 obviously these are all
CG creations which is why they didn't
include them in the previous trailers
because they're still working on all the
visual effects reverse-flash was
supposed to be leading this army so
maybe he shows up right before this big
battle happens in whichever episode that
winds up being the reason we probably
haven't seen them is because they've
been spending most of their time in
these trailers focusing on the pariah
version of Welles and Tom Cavanagh is
playing all these different characters
if you look in this big fight scene
there's all these pillars and pylons
with advance looking technology bursting
through the floorboards in this regular
looking Lobby so this probably has
something to do with the monitors cosmic
tuning forks the big towers that they
can struck during comic book crisis on
Infinite Earths it's just part of his
plan to try and stop the antimatter wave
but as we see it looks like it's
completely unsuccessful also notice that
Ray Palmer is in most of the early
footage on earth 38 and Kingdom Come
superman brain and ralph is in all the
later footage so unless this blue energy
that just winks him out is portaling him
somewhere else
early r.i.p - Ray Palmer this shot of
Superman a Supergirl against the red sky
is also interesting because they're
using their powers and you think that
the yellow Sun being blotted out by the
red antimatter wave would dampen them in
some way the whole reason why you would
want to turn the sky red would be to
neutralize them Barry gets really
curious about some weird-looking cosmic
energy that we haven't seen before this
is Sarah in what looks like Lois Lane in
the white jacket in the future team
arrow bunker where everything is run
down then flash recruits black lightning
on the wave
that's not happening till episode 3 he
might show up at the tail end of episode
2 in a tag scene or something like that
then everybody press F in the chat 438
the monitor did tease that he can bring
Earth's back that had been wiped but it
would be cool if they use Crysis Earth's
will live Earth's will die and the
universe will never be the same
to merge super girls show with the earth
one characters that way all the heroes
can be on earth one we already have our
earth one Batman now canonized as Kevin
Conroy so you basically have all your
big Justice League characters - a Wonder
Woman although I do believe they've been
trying to get Linda Carter in a cameo so
that may have happened because they
finished filming the crossover a while
ago so for those of you asking about
that tag scene where he became pariah
from the comics it just confirms some of
the theories that we had earlier this
season it just made sense based on his
mission of trying to attain this
knowledge and take down the monitor that
he would be turned into comic book
pariah the whole idea here is that he
gained access to the secret sanctum
these seven symbols correlate to the
seven different Paragons although it's
not clear which symbol correlates to
which Paragon but when the voice of the
monitor grants him access and you see
the door open and he's bathed in this
light that just blots him out that's him
attaining this cosmic knowledge my next
video will be for the mid-season finale
of the flash they'll be teeing up crisis
and wrapping up their negative flash art
but while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new Black Widow
trailer and click here for the other big
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]